hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba do a
lot actually Edna I'm Morgan hand
tattoos in Morgan and Ashley is their
YouTube channel I was recently on a
video with them
the patriotic I drink with them just
watch go to their channel you'll find
okay do you guys ever breathe transition
for her trailer number one it stars
Andrew Garfield
Fryman spider-man oh yeah and it's
directed by Andy Serkis your gosh : yeah
and Cesar employment of the apes right
just so everyone knows I'm really sure
that Frodo would not have gotten to
where he was without Sam and that's all
I'm going to say we're talking about
Laura's rings
we're not let's watch the trailer I
could all see the dome and you could say
well I don't feel like I can say
or we can just go home okay you don't
think some by force okay about respect
to estranged and he needs I've never
visited people paralyzed and curly Oberg
last long
coming with a typical yet are competing
with yourself
they're ever like this yes you sir
nothing and I won't join us today
oh yes I can things become please can do
[Music]
know my much better boy pants that never
make us you know
now inculcated an idea a wheelchair
because he's waiting for himself what
mystery thief there may five pounds I
mean why didn't keep your disabled
people in prison no believes is possible
to live as you do while we can open the
gates in seconds crane more reliable and
therefore will not be an adventure when
I first attempt hours I wanted to die my
wife told me I happen
ah yo your life is you turn back I don't
want to just survive
I live in Chile
I think you shouldn't know Wow crap as
you call me on my own oh she's going to
see bears and wonder are you okay it
doesn't it looks bad it's that's gonna
be a sad one to get through out of his
side it was so great well yes and very
much okay to not savage an emotional
movie yeah that's for damn sure
hmm it's worth construe that's what yeah
Andrew Garfield is great at playing
people who are suffering and have to
remain optimistic he does it hacks are
rich I really want to do just suffering
and just trying to keep his head above
anything that movie silence or he's that
priest who has a goal and he's just
trying to keep the space alive while
they suffering and here's another one it
is these roles that really rely on love
and faith to keep him alive you can't
agree on the fireman you spider-man when
I was before all that but that there's
Carrie cousins or some similar things in
love with you Josh Huestis he's not
level becomes gamma man guys young
layers man I think you did a fantastic
job one of these days this guy's gonna
get an Oscar I can just see a grown man
maybe maybe we don't know this might be
Andy Serkis first time directing a guy
who's known for motion capture directing
this is that he's doing a jungle book
movie which is supposed to be completely
different from the one that we got
recently ah I buy a lot darker version
now well and that's the one we'll have
like what we would think any circus ague
the motion captures yeah but here this
is such an interesting the thing for him
this I guess this is good for him to do
before he does like his huge Hollywood
film because he can get yeah he's still
working behind the camera but if a film
look shot beautifully it looks
wonderfully done and any story about
luck and
and yes like um that one with URI of
everything yeah yeah that's what I
thought oh yeah
and see that and the other one were the
guys in the wheelchair me before you
yeah a yellow kind of movie I did yeah
it does so sad why I love it
love that motivation to keep on moving
and the themes of not just surviving
with truly living love is beautiful well
this guy really meant it like the
wheelchair like he did it mostly oh
really
I was no it wasn't him doing it away why
didn't things well I guess it was his
idea
so I didn't probably was happy yeah but
know how cool now right no that was
really cool that she was like why can't
we just move him or he was like I wanna
leave which is like alright let's make
it happen it was kind of a foul that the
ultimate teamwork
clearly broke the law by doing yes I
didn't know that you kept me on yeah I
mean I wasn't leave it I like these
period pieces yeah a little drama I'm
sure any time they were it's really
about love and their crying I'm they're
probably gonna be in the theater too
baby
ah so hard yeah oh we have to bring a
lot of tissues to that one I'm excited I
can't wait to see it yeah yeah a pumped
and I'm sure he hasn't lose for super
long but I mean I thought at least maybe
anyone was about lunch at 11:00 so much
and you were like something's going to
happen I was like okay this is going to
be terrible and then when I saw him get
sick consequently she was not and not
like in like cheating on her or both of
them being mean to me show yeah yeah and
then they stayed together and it was
triumphing well I mean even if he
doesn't live for long it seems like the
theme of it is not about how long you
live but the quality yes quality of life
and her sure and sure he probably lived
longer than if he had been in that one
place the whole entire time and
Gandia me your mobile and then plus he
you have the invention to help other
people later on oh yeah way to go and
Igor feels like a motivational and very
sad movie
I'm soul ride anyone trying to be under
you well guys don't forget to breathe
this Christmas for whenever he comes the
house subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification Bell how do you
do stuff with actually in Morgan kind of
check out their channel is not a brief
of absolutely I'm Morgan actually the
proper way to read is when you inhale
through the nose yet the your stomach
anything out mmm-hmm a lot of people I
make the mistake when they breathe in
there's there I'm focused on their
stomach or they're sucking in when they
breathe in but the problem is I focus on
breathing too much sometimes ya know it
can happen like when I meditate when I
focus when I focus on my breathing my
heart's beating a little C it's
important how to your video right there
for you guys and also check out that
video that I did with then check out our
patreon a lot of fun stuff over there Oh
[Music]
bye